marianne it is my pleasure to officially
welcome you to the survivor winner
circle and i am so proud of you for
keeping the crown in canada
congratulations
how are you feeling my goodness million
erica educa it is so nice to finally
talk to you and meet you i'm feeling
great oh my goodness i i i'm probably
feeling the same way you were feeling
it's a surreal experience you know it
there is nothing quite like it so i need
to ask you
why are canadians so good at survivor
specifically canadian women there's
something in the water there's got to be
something in the water about like why
we're good and i think the thing in the
water we've and we've been wanting to
play this game for so long and you know
we were finally allowed to play we're
like what we're going to play we're
going to show that we earned it and
we've taken it two seasons in a row
i think people need to be scared i think
that people underestimate nice canadians
but you should be scared if you see a
canadian on the beach someone says a
boot you boot them out
[Laughter]
that's right eh
yeah
well your win was also historic for
another type of representation you are
the second black woman to ever win in
the franchise how does that feel
oh my goodness it feels amazing to know
that i'm going to go and be
representation for people who watch
these shows but i think the bigger
picture of it is that when we have a
more diverse cast you get to have more
first like for example you're the first
filipino woman to win survivor if mike
won he i don't i think he'd be the first
puerto rican man to win also the oldest
if romeo won he would have been the
first gay man to win since survivor
season 15. so i hope to see a lot more
first like this is historic but i hope
that i'm so not only the black community
is able to be uplifted but more and more
different communities and marginalized
communities will be able to be uplifted
yes we need to see all sorts of people
winning and speaking of your win i feel
like you had so many wonderful moments
in the finale was there a point during
the last few days of the game or even
during the final tribal council where
you thought i've got this
oh my goodness i feel as if when i got
taken to final three i felt as if i had
a good chance to win it'd be a little
bit harder with mike but then that final
try but when everyone was just
continually talking to mike i'm like oh
my gosh they don't even see me like i
guess i overplayed like i guess i didn't
think about it when people started to
talk to me and i was able to articulate
my game i'm like okay no i have a chance
i feel as if i have a chance again
oh amazing well in your final tribal
council which i think was so impressive
i think there were so many great moments
the you revealing your idol um i think
the way that you articulated that
everything you did was intentional was
so good we had a fan on twitter conman81
asked
when did you realize that being young
and strategic was really threatening
oh my goodness i think i realized that
by the way that people were discussing
when at the merge with tori like people
were like tory's trying to strategize
how dare she do this how dare but i'm
going and watching other people
strategize it's like tori was playing
the exact same game as other people but
because she was extra and like because
she had a bad rep and was strategizing
that was seen as negative also when i
heard about like why swathi was voted
out it's like oh sophie had a number one
deal with everyone it's like everyone
talks to everyone so it's like there was
this negative perception where if you're
young and strategized we weren't allowed
to do that so i had to then go and
really take a little bit of a step back
because i didn't want to be on the jury
oh i love that i love that it's like
don't underestimate her
whatever you think is going to be a
weakness she's taking it and she's
bringing it to the end of course so
when it comes to your survivor
experience
you were saying you weren't just playing
to win the million dollars what do you
feel like you gained from that
experience
i think the thing that i really gained
from that experience was validation to
never be the one to reject yourself like
i talked about is what final travel
where i really wanted to go and play my
idol on lindsay because then if lindsay
want to be like oh well you know
lindsay's such a good player it makes
sense rather than trying to give myself
the best position to win and then after
do everything i can and then still lose
in the end so that's something which i
really took away where it's like always
try your best if it doesn't work out it
sucks but at least you know that you
gave yourself every single available
option to do so
i i totally feel that 100 don't
self-eliminate this is our message to
future canadian women who want to play
don't take yourself out of the runny get
in there oh yeah so now that you've
reached this monumental win what is next
for marianne
oh my goodness what's next catching up
on sleep
and more long term i'm probably i just
graduated a couple weeks ago for my
master's so i'm probably going to take a
year off and work and then after i might
look into going back to school because
apparently i love learning but just the
world's my oyster
it is and can i suggest on your to-do
list we need to have dinner we need to
meet we need a meeting of the winners
yes we we can afford it we can split the
bill no one has to treat the other we
can afford it we'll go dutch we'll go
dutch i'll recommend the cactus club
cafe i love cactus floyd okay toronto i
want
i'll give you some stressful reps i'll
buy you some oh oh okay new winner is
treating me oh yeah
well marianne it was so much fun to
watch you play i am so proud of you i'm
so happy you have kept the crown in
canada and i cannot wait to see what you
do next and i'm i'm pumped for our
dinner so thank you so much so excited
thank you for having me
you